Sky News presenter Sarah Hewson and her
family have been selected so Sarah what
does this actually consists of what are
you going to have to do to take part in
this sorry I should say where there is a
Jack who's and her eldest boy so we
received a letter about two and a half
weeks ago Adam from the Office of
National Statistics and the University
of Oxford asking us infection study and
what it entails is a series of swab test
which we self administer at home over
the course of the next year now we had
the first one of those on Monday we
received a call on Sunday evening from a
nurse who said she'd be coming around on
Monday it's a no contact visit so you
can see I'm in the garden doing it so
the nurse came around the side of our
house into the garden brought us the
test kits gave us some instructions and
then we had to administer them ourselves
myself and my husband and then I had to
do this robbing of our three children
Jack who's with me who's seven a toy
who's five and Freya who's three our
next test that you to be next week and
we'll be tested and then monthly for a
year so it's 16 tests in total in order
for government scientists to try and
build up a picture of the spread of the
infection within the population and Jack
what's it like having this test throat
is the worst bit but the nervous is just
tickly it makes you laugh and the throat
bit why didn't you like that it makes
you cough and splutter but it doesn't
hurt and it's very quick isn't it yeah
it's not that the nose bits the worse
because it goes right up your nose but
you found that okay did you Jack yeah
your brother wasn't so keen on the nose
bit what he says never
again it means quite difficult as a mum
to administer I'm not medically trained
I don't really know what I'm doing I
took the instructions and obviously when
you've got a small child squirming and
and gagging as you do it you don't want
to hurt them but you also know you need
to get this form as you say out and then
the nose is quite uncomfortable you have
to get it far enough into the nose to
get enough of a sample for those it's
quite difficult as a mum to be doing
that to the children but as I said we've
got 16 of these tests to do so I think
we'll probably get used to it by the end
Jack I mean you're you're being
homeschooled at the moment what do you
think about this whole coronavirus thing
are you very scared or not really scared
because it makes people pass away and
that's upsetting for people who lose
lost ones and it's also quite upsetting
for me because I can't see my friends I
can't see my grandparents it just
doesn't feel right
is it a compensation being off school
though well we do get mostly the
afternoons we go out onto the common and
play after work normally get it done
quite quickly and we have more time to
relax very good of you to take part in
this Sarah and family I think there's
six of you all together and I mean it's
quite a long-term commitment this isn't
it yes it is that nobody has to complete
every test if they want to pull out at
any point but they can we felt it was
quite important to do our bit there's so
little that we do know about this virus
so the more that we can do to help sign
understand it and as we know the
majority of testing has only been taking
place in hospitals and now more in care
homes are not more widely in the
community so if we can help with that
and also from a more selfish point of
view and it's quite interesting for us
and quite useful for us to be tested
regularly to see what happens I mean
that the children and my husband are at
home all the time my husband's working
from home I'm obviously going into work
but we're not doing huge amounts but my
middle child and my youngest will be
going back to school in a nursery in
June and I suppose from that point on it
also becomes more interesting and more
informative and useful for us to know
where we are but so far it's good news
for the family houston's so the swabs
are done on Monday then they're sent to
a lab and then the data goes to the
University of Oxford and the office for
national statistics for analysis and
then those results will then be fed back
to our GP who then tells us whether we
were negative or positive I mean none of
us are symptomatic and we don't have any
symptoms at the moment but obviously
that's part of what this survey is about
looking to see how many people may have
the virus that be asymptomatic good luck
with that and Sarah Jack thank you very
much